is the rajapaksa political dynasty in
sri lanka about to end
president gotta buy rajapaksa is under
pressure to resign after his brother
mahinda stepped down as prime minister
that that wasn't enough to calm violent
protests so where does sri lanka go from
here this is inside story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm nastasia tay now for months
protesters have been chanting go home at
sri lanka's most powerful political
family president gotsabaya rajapaksa and
his brother prime minister mahinda
rajapaksa are accused of corruption and
mismanaging the economy mahinda's
resignation on monday failed to quell
public anger at least seven people were
killed more than 200 injured after
rajapaksa supporters fought with
anti-government protesters police and
security personnel fired tear gas water
cannon demonstrators tried to storm the
prime minister's residence and set fire
to properties owned by the rajapaksa
family and government ministers
the president has given the military and
police even more powers to detain people
without warrants
shortages of fuel food and medicine
brought thousands out onto the streets
and protests that had been mostly
peaceful until this week minell
fernandez has more now from the capital
colombo
calm restored more or less in most parts
of the country as the curfew extended
now obviously helped by a big presence
of the three armed forces supporting the
police
we had members of the army the air force
uh the navy stopping us at different
points checking us as to where we were
going because obviously there's a curfew
in sri lanka till wednesday morning
many people don't seem to be heeding the
curfew in terms of even you can see some
of the scenes behind me those burnt out
wreckages there are four buses and this
was the scene right throughout many
parts of colombo close to the prime
minister's official residence which is
just down the road obviously these were
the buses that brought in many of the
supporters of the prime minister
that subsequently marched on the
protesters who are demanding the
resignations of the rajapaksa brothers
and their government
but
when they tried to go back
to their homes to their villages
they had their just deserts the
protesters say they were giving
these supporters a taste of their own
medicine that they were absolutely fed
up of intimidation and strong arm
tactics that the raj boxes have been
employing for a long long time now
internationally there's been
condemnation of the violence we've heard
that the
commissioner of human rights michele
bachelet in geneva has condemned the
violence asking for a proper
investigation into what sparked the
violence and these incidents for the
protesters themselves the fact that the
prime minister has resigned does not go
far enough their rallying cry for this
campaign was gotta go home
and they did specify and continue to
stand by the fact they want a clean
sweep so the president the government
they all need to go in order for the
protesters to be appeased manila
fernandez inside story
while sri lanka's economic crisis has
been brewing since 2019 when the
government started dipping into foreign
reserves to pay its debt revenues
dropped in 2020 when exports fell after
the pandemic also ground the tourism
industry there to a halt
and agricultural output suffered last
year when the government banned
fertilizers and ordered farmers to go
organic by march the situation was dire
sri lanka couldn't pay for imports of
food medicine fuel people faced power
cuts lasting up to 13 hours a day
the government tried to contain
discontent by shutting down social media
and declaring a state of emergency but
protests grew and in early april sri
lanka's entire cabinet resigned
well let's now bring in our guests
joining us from colombo is harsha de
silva he's a member of sri lanka's
parliament in the main opposition party
we also have ganeshan wigner raja he's a
senior research associate at the
overseas development institute he joins
us from london and also joining us from
the sri lankan capital is bhavani
fonseca she's a senior researcher and
attorney at law with the center for
policy alternatives a very warm welcome
to each of you thank you for your time
on our program i want to ask because
we've been seeing these protests
continue now for weeks months
they've been mostly peaceful bhavani i
know you've been out on the streets what
do you think has triggered this level of
violence that we've seen
so thank you for having me and it's a
timely discussion considering what's
happening in sri lanka
the protest as you said has been rather
peaceful in the last two months we
commenced the um
protests in the suburbs of colombo in
early march and it's spread across sri
lanka with a large
protest in the center of colombo and it
has been peaceful all this time what
happened yesterday was when the
protesters were outside
the official residence of the prime
minister
there were goons associated with the
government who went and attacked the
peaceful protesters and continued to
travel to the other side which was the
larger site and that's where also some
violence happened so really peaceful
protest by citizens for two months
and the violence really needs to be
directly attributed to the prime
minister and the government because so
far we did not see any violence coming
from the protesters still yesterday
well i understand there was some sort of
meeting with the pro-government
protesters ahead of the violence that
some ministers were also present calling
for action of some sort now we've
obviously seen homes and officers
torched does that mean the government
side is backing down or or hasha do you
think we'll see further confrontations
well i actually hope not because it has
completely gotten out of control
and there is no government there is no
prime minister there is no cabinet
and i don't know whether the police are
able to act
we haven't seen the president he's holed
up somewhere um so things are very very
dicey right now
so to get the country back to some sense
of
normalcy
we need to urgently have a government in
place
so that the law enforcement officers can
control these mobs
because otherwise they could go berserk
well this is all obviously taking place
within the context of this very dire
economic crisis that we've been talking
about i see a former finance minister
warned that some have got to buy
rajapaksa's policies especially those
sweeping tax cuts that we've previously
covered on this show would send the
country bankrupt
but it seems like this level of profound
anger that we're seeing goes beyond that
there's this sense of betrayal
ganesha where do you think that's coming
from
essentially the crisis is a function of
both the pandemic which left deep
scarring on the sri lankan economy
growth slipped to minus 3.6 in 2020 and
policy missteps by the government and
the policy missteps do include indeed
the tax cut of
2019 which lost revenue of about 2
percent of gdp but also printing money
which led to a hyperinflation which we
face today uh inflation on a
year-on-year basis to april is about 30
percent and food inflation is running at
practically 50 percent and then you've
had this rapid switch
from chemical fertilizers to organic
fertilizers which without preparing
farmers which has radically affected
agriculture so this combination of
external events and policy missteps are
leading us to where we are the only
other point i want to add to this is
that a communication by the government
was very poor
and people were not prepared for this
dire situation we were in we were told
that there were these non-conventional
policies that were being done which
would save the country but this has
proved to be uh totally wrong
well given that the resignation we saw
of the prime minister who enacted a lot
of these policies it seems to have done
very little to appease the protesters
many are now asking if this is actually
going to be the end of the rajapaksa era
now just to remind our viewers the
rajapaksas have been one of sri lanka's
most powerful political families since
the 1930s mahinda rajapaksa first became
president in 2005 and he soon appointed
his younger brother gotta buy as defense
secretary and placed other family
members in senior political positions
four years later mahinda gained praise
for ending the civil war against the
tamil tigers but he was also accused of
violating human rights and crushing
dissent gotabaya himself then won the
presidency in 2019. he then appointed
his brother mahinda prime minister aya
laser two other rajapaksa family members
were also appointed ministers many
others also hold senior positions
it's believed that brothers controlled
up to 70 of sri lanka's budget at one
point now the family denies this and has
repeatedly rejected allegations of
nepotism
i see though that there are a number of
other rajapaksas who've been in
ministerial or other senior positions
who've now been removed
basil rajapaksa the finance minister
accused of corruption jamal rajapaksa
minister of irrigation his son shasindra
who led that whole fertilizer ban also
gone mahinda's son namal also at one
point minister of youth and sports he
said the family is now going through a
bad patch
hasha is it more than that more than a
bad patch
well yes i mean that's putting it mildly
uh the situation in the
the treasury and the central bank
is nothing to
you know be happy about
we are in
serious trouble uh we need
some sort of bridge financing uh to make
sure that we have sufficient um
[Music]
fuel
lp gas coal
and without
the
coffers sufficiently filled to purchase
these items
we have long power cuts
we have long lines of fuel and so on
so the situation is pretty bad
we need to really
be able to quickly
put a plan uh in action uh to be able to
uh deal with the situation so it's more
than a bad patch it's a pretty terrible
situation well looking at the leadership
specifically i wonder is there more at
stake here for the rajapaksa than simply
staying in power i know given there have
been allegations of human rights abuses
war crimes from the tamil tiger
crackdown
could the brothers then be concerned
about some kind of accountability for
that bhavani i want to point out here
mahindra's already been refusing probes
still hasn't been a proper investigation
do you think that's
what bleeding into this
i think there's a combination but
definitely there are serious allegations
against particular individuals in the
family
and this is both on
corruption issues as well as what's
happening in the
past during the war as well as post-war
so it's very serious allegations which
has now gone to the u.n and there are
also cases in other jurisdiction so
there is a fear that if they lose power
that these cases can come back to haunt
them
now we're also seeing what we saw
yesterday in terms of the violence and
coming back to what the protesters face
we need to recognize that the violence
started
from the president's res prime
minister's residence and there is
footage to show that there were
not just the prime minister and his son
but there were the ministers so there
needs to be an independent investigation
whether particularly individuals in the
family as well as the former cabinet and
i say former because we don't now have a
government are responsible for
incitement and organizing some of this
violence so there are serious
allegations against many not just the
rajapaksa family but those around them
as well and the question is can there be
accountability for all of them this in a
context where there were serious cases
that were brought against them in 2015
onwards and those cases didn't proceed
so lots of questions where the
accountability can happen in the present
setup but there are lots of allegations
and i fear that they're holding on to
power because they're preventing those
cases from moving forward but there is
also by my understanding an ethnic
dimension here that i think is
potentially quite telling so
the rajapaksas are always banked on
their support from the sinali's buddhist
community majority 75 of the population
but we've also seen them join these
protests in in fairly huge numbers
ganeshan do you think that that's
pushing towards political change here
so in a context of a post-conflict
society like ours one had hoped that
when the rajapaksas had concluded the
civil conflict in 2009 there would be an
attempt to heal the wounds as you have
had in south africa in ireland and in
other places which have been
conflict-driven sadly that had not
proved to be the case
and if anything there was an element of
triumphalism and what is very
interesting with the current protest at
least as i observe it is that you've had
multi-ethnic protest coming around and i
think this is an interesting and
unforeseen development in our society
and hopefully a positive step and
we certainly need
if we are going to prosper and grow
we will need to heal the wounds of a
long conflict and the ethnic divisions
that we have had because no country can
really develop and grow very fast if
they are ethnically divided
and had these perpetual bouts of
instability as we have sadly seen so we
have to rethink a lot of what we have
done in the past and introduce
proper policy measures and provide a
proper rule of law if we want to move
forward i was trying to gauge public
opinion around all of this and i was
looking at some surveys i see gallup put
confidence in the government at record
lows heading downward at the end of last
year another poll the approval rating
for the government was 10
back in january um
how much support you're sitting in the
opposition i'm curious how much support
does the government have do you think
and and what are the demographics here
that make up the bulk of that support
ongoing
well i don't think the government has
any support any longer i mean yesterday
was uh uh
absolutely turning point
because the government
it was
all for everyone to see
called up goons and thugs to the
official residents of the prime minister
and let them lose on the protesters and
what they didn't expect
was the reaction of the general public
you know they caught the thugs and threw
them into lakes and burnt buses and
unfortunately several people also
lost their lives
so if there was any confidence left in
these people that just dissipated
yesterday
so
now
we are like i said at the beginning in a
very precarious situation
where that confidence need to be rebuilt
and the only way that confidence can be
rebuilt in my view is to have a new
government uh hopefully the president uh
would resign
because the la the cry for his uh
resignation has gotten
uh even louder uh post yesterday uh
because otherwise we are going to go
into some
crisis i mean of course we are in a huge
crisis unprecedented crisis and it could
even worsen and i
started to think what might happen uh if
there is no political solution in the
next 24-48 hours bhavani how realistic
do you think that is do you think that
the president might resign especially
now that he has these emergency powers
and he's also now given officers the
power to detain and question without
arrest warrants
well i mean i'm glad you raised this the
pass of the executive presidency is
enormous and this was consolidated under
this precedent under the 20th amendment
so this president for weeks have been
hearing the calls or one assumes he
heard the calls of the protesters
calling for his resignation a survey we
did also showed that 87 percent wanted
the president to resign
now that's a huge number if you really
think about it a significant portion
including his own base and regardless
he's held on to power now i don't see
him leaving that easily and that is the
unfortunate situation that him holding
on to this office this all powerful
office is having a huge detriment to
this country and its citizens so i fear
that unless there's more pressure
brought for to
make the precedent resign we're going to
see much much more dire times that said
i just want to say this the president
resigning doesn't mean we are left in a
vacuum the constitution provides
for a
prime minister to be appointed and a
president to be appointed by parliament
so there are specific measures provided
in the constitution that can be taken
very quickly as soon as the president
resigns so this is the most critical
urgent need right now well let me ask
then if the rajapaksas are removed
ganesha and given the dire state of the
economy you're an economist the
challenges are obviously likely to
continue we could see austerity measures
these could be very painful for many
people in sri lanka who are already
suffering
even with these economic realities then
do you think we could see discontent
continue
so i think that sri lanka can eventually
come out of this dire situation if we
put in place the right policies and we
have
political will and one has seen this
elsewhere
in the developing world where countries
have come out of such serious situations
so i have a little bit of optimism for
sri lanka but we need to do at least
three things to try to get this back on
track the first is we need to
restructure the foreign debt
which is held by private creditors
that's the majority of the debt and also
the bilateral creditors and that
includes china and india as well as
japan and that's quite a tricky set of
conversations that have to be held the
second thing is we've got to
agree on and implement fully an imf
program on macroeconomic stability and
debt management and that is going to be
quite a complex discussion because there
are two bits of money that will have to
come there is a short bit of money under
a rapid financing facility some 400
million dollars and then there is
something called an enhanced program
from the imf which is about 3 billion or
1 billion a year which will have to come
and we'll have to show substantial
progress in debt restructuring and
that's the tricky bit and the third
thing which government has to do whoever
comes into power is to put in place a
program of structural reforms to
deregulate the economy to green it and
to ensure inclusiveness and and that
that in that program is is essential and
very few governments in sri lanka's
history have actually reformed
the economy well and there are three
important elements in that reform the
first we've got to cut red tape which is
strangling business
and that's critical the second is we've
got to encourage women's participation
in economic activity women's
participation rates are low and this is
a problem in an aging society
i i do want to bring in hasha there
because what it sounds like you're
saying is that wholesale economic change
is necessary but then harsha let me ask
you does wholesale economic change
require wholesale political change as
you see it
yes and i think i agree with
what ganesha said but you know we need
to be able to get these reforms done but
you need to have the political will to
do it and like he said nobody really had
that will previously do it and i think
this is the best time to get all these
structural reforms done however
we need to ensure that people are
cushioned somehow so i will have to add
a fourth point to history and that is a
very strong social protection system so
we need to be able to
to protect the people who are going to
be the worst hit with these reforms so
those are the things that we are
thinking about right now because if we
take government in the next few days
that is the first thing we would need to
do and the imf is fully on board with
that plan um and um we hope that we will
succeed bhavani i want to ask you
something that harsha alluded to a
little bit earlier in our conversation
and taking a step back from all of this
i've seen speculation on part of various
different people in sri lanka that this
is part of a conversation that could
shape a country do you think that the
protests that we've seen the process
that we're in now
is this part of nation building
definitely i believe we have this um
unique opportunity and i think that's a
very important thing to remember
you know while we've seen the violence
of the last 24 hours the last few weeks
showed that citizens have come out
peacefully united there's been some
issues but i mean recognizing that
there's a lot to do but people can be
united in building this country and
there's also recognition
that there needs to be structural
reforms brought in that changes the
structure of this country so one of the
key reforms that people are now coming
behind is abolishing the executive
presidency now if things like that
the devolution of power reconciliation
economic justice all of that can come
together
we have this
unique opportunity to really push this
country forward and bring in stability
and economic growth but you know these
are long-term plans i think immediately
what we need is to have a government
that gives people the confidence that
this is possible and that's the problem
right now
well it is a very tricky situation for
sri lanka thank you so much for joining
us to discuss what's happening on the
ground now we'll be watching it very
closely here on al jazeera thank you to
all of our guests harsha da silva
ganeshan wigna raja and bhavani fonseca
and thank you too for watching you can
see the program again any time by
visiting our website that's
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
do go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story and you remember you can also join
the conversation on twitter our handle
is at aj inside story from me
anastasiotay and the whole team here in
doha bye for now
[Music]
you